foreign
okay
oh man I'm getting some like Matrix
Vibes remember when they go above the
the smog surfaces this
gorgeous yes Brian this looks so good
the effects are incredible in this
episode I kind of want to be in the
fireworks show down below yeah is this
the first time in Star Wars where I've
wanted to just be watching it all from
below rather be in it you want to be on
the in the Empire I mean I didn't say
that but if you get that view okay how
could you uh how could you turn that
down yeah I did it for the views that's
a new one put that thing down
catch our breath
split up the winnings
oh
got him hands
Corner oh man
I feel like he was just testing him no
you're just been testing him surely he
was just testing him
what just happened and Andor says I'm
not even risking it maybe and or was
just like enough games yeah he's like I
don't know if you're testing me or not
but like what a mean test yeah I don't
like these kind of tests anymore I've
clearly proven my words to you exactly I
think that's it I think he's like come
on I have to survive like I don't know
what's going I don't know you guys
either you can't just keep testing me
I'm like eventually I'm gonna be like
wait am I getting screwed over here so
also anyone that's like we could split
it is definitely gonna kill you shoot
you in the back the second you turn
around yeah that's true no that's true
nope yeah don't play games when you're
on this kind of high stakes Mission I
think it's a lesson in that welcome back
to new rock stars and or episode 6 did
not disappoint with the eye of aldani a
gripping hour of Television uh or
whatever you call this uh streaming
content on whatever device you watched
it on I was on the edge of my seat and
it proves For Better or Worse everyone
has their own Rebellion even her boy
cousin from the bear who lied about his
pepper picking brother come on man but
how is the Empire gonna retaliate oh
what's gonna happen next for all of
these characters because you know we're
kind of at the midpoint of the show
we're really all asking what comes next
we'll get our answers when you fix this
and door
I wanted it on that one you did it this
is Wookie leaks our weekly and or
reaction show I'm here with Tommy bech
told Tommy oh thoughts on this episode
man you know I gotta say I should have
been more aware when he called it a
pepper tree I mean peppers grow on
Plants right peppers are plants they
grow on vines I don't know I mean these
are plants I don't know what peppers
grow I was thinking small like sapling
sized trees you know or maybe this is
Star Wars they call all kinds of things
maybe maybe someone in the comments will
remind us of all the peppers that grow
on trees in in a loving yeah I'm sure
either way R.I.P cousin Richie uh what
was his name skeem Marvel scheme scheme
no one named skein survives in Star Wars
I'm sorry you get the last name Skeen
you're doomed uh there's no he's cousin
Skeen cousin Cousin Skeeter oh maybe
we'll get Cousin Skeeter and Elena a
Nickelodeon Star Wars Crossing yeah we
have more puppets yeah like but not like
Max Rebo puppets I mean like just people
puppets that know their puppets I almost
just said oh come on would that be
hilarious if they had puppets in Star
Wars forgetting that one of the most
popular characters in all of Star Wars
is the puppet Yoda
to break my hearts hobby what are you
talking about
Green you're right I'm sorry
why could you say that do you think
Cousin Skeeter was self-aware and knew
that he had a hand up his butt yeah
absolutely I think he liked it that's
why he was always smiling uh
um hey so something interesting about
Arville skiing now if this whole story
about his pepper picking farmer brother
was a lie that means he really thought
this through of like okay well not only
that the Empire flooded his farm and
then he paddled about to the middle of
that flood plain and then he built his
pockets filled with rocks and then he
jumped in and he's like I can't swim and
he sunk all the way to the bottom and
that's why I'm fighting for the like I
was with him I believed him on his story
my heart broke how could you do this to
a scheme he's a great actor he truly is
I mean Elon musk's background an amazing
actor I give this guy his own yeah I
mean part of me is like good move him on
to something else now now we can enjoy
him and something else that's true like
put him in another show House of the
Dragon season two why not
yeah I'd watch them in that so let's
recap everything that happened this
episode so we can look to what happens
next on this show now that we're in its
midpoint episode six again such a great
hour of television or whatever this was
nemec tells Cassian that you can sleep
because he has too much to believe in uh
when you're a True Believer you're just
gonna be tossing and turning all night
and then he just like says well you have
nothing he's like you have nothing you
start sounding which I just I very much
enjoyed uh uh but Cassie says nimik will
sleep well when it's over and you know
what Tommy he does yeah sleeping with
the angels although I gotta say a little
bit of that's on him I know we're
probably gonna get to it why was he
positioned like that on the on the
freighter trying to escape I mean a
couple of things in this episode that
I'll bring up later but go go ahead
please continue yeah yeah you're right
he was uh what don't stand behind some
loose fat stacks you know you see how
heavy those are they they take a dolly
to move in there everything's loose
don't stand next to some loose stuff you
know the purple maybe that's a thing I
mean Cassie did call out how little they
knew about the propulsion of this stuff
without away it properly and I think
that was kind of a red flag or someone's
gonna get crushed and probably some
Marxist uh symbolism there right Capital
destroys all I think is what we learned
from that point yeah I wish that he had
kind of like popped a little bit you
know like it had squished him in like
his eyeballs bulged out like a sausage I
wanted him to go oh
that's gonna leave a mark
Oh Daddy
yeah that would have been great uh I
wanted Val to get some like um what do
they call that like Mama Grizzly
strength when the babies yeah yeah yeah
yeah super yeah when they can like lift
a car just lift the money uh anyway we
meet Gorn supervisor Corporal j-hold
bihas I love the names on this show uh
glob Shadow is is his name I believe uh
but he greets the Imperial engineer from
Coruscant no one particular VIP just
another smug jerk who has his goofy
little telescope to look at the star
shower what a jerk
um Colonel pedagar is his name and Bs
has also a wife and a son at the base I
love this show everyone's got a family
that they go home to and uh the son no
fan of the Imperial lifestyle j-hold as
a sash that doesn't fit him right
anymore I kind of wanted him to yell at
his son to get the what's it called the
sash stretcher go get my leather my
leather puncher or whatever my my life
like those things where you like make
another loop in your belt or whatever
yeah yeah go get my punch you mean a
knife yeah some scissors yes get me my
sewing kit because it's time to become a
seamstress again we learned that
terraman was a former Stormtrooper but
also this comes from skiing so who knows
yeah who knows
um but uh Gorn disguises them as Al
Kenzie's sentries they squirt the 60 or
so aldani pilgrims to the temple where
the pilgrims partake in this goat Pelt
exchange ritual with the corporal's
family the pilgrims just burned the
spell and they start one hell of a party
and uh Tommy we were talking about this
earlier but like yeah in Star Wars the
exciting the most beautiful place to be
usually is Right In the Heat of the
battle you know in the above the orbit
of the planet but this is the first time
where it wanted me to be in those
deleted scenes with the 1977 film where
Luke and and his friends are just
looking up at the Battle overhead in the
sky that's kind of where I wanted to be
here I want to be with like the the
ground folks looking at this beautiful
action overhead like not only is that
safer to be that's just where the most
beautiful imagery yeah is I wanted to be
like the common people I want to be
where the people are that's right
um want to see want to see him watching
walking around on those what do you call
them Max repo's feet oh repo feet he
uses what he uses the feet to play the
organ
I think puppet feet is a good improv
team name so Tommy and I are gonna start
doing a Duo show coming to the new rock
stars Burbank back theater that's right
coming soon well I mean if you could if
we are in Burbank most people believe
we're in Vancouver yeah oh oops
on Vancouver Street in Burbank that's
right our own employees can't even get
into that building that's right no one
knows how to get in here or get out it's
just a hand I'm I'm like the other I'm
like the uh I'm like bihas you just use
my hand and that's how you get it but
only me so if I don't show up early we
don't work uh it's Tommy's the key to
all of this so velen sent to approach
the dam from the lake uh some really
cool underwater shots here
um and they installed some comms Jammers
the rebels take the Corporal in his
family hostage pretty brutal choices but
I think it was really skiing who was
just shoving that gun in the kid's head
I was like yikes scheme the kids I guess
he understands the the motivation but I
mean had he been in the room when that
father was talking to his family earlier
I don't know if they would have viewed
the family as the proper motivation uh
the engineer nearly kills nemec but
Sinta takes down this engineer they
leave Santa behind to guard the control
room they use the Corporal to break in
the vault force him and his men to load
those fat stacks of credits onto the
freighter the alkenzie air base calls in
when the vault is breached and sends a
squad of Thai fighters I love that we
start with these Pilots uh running down
the catwalk to lower into their I just
love it anytime we can actually see the
pilots enter like the thing you know
most of the time it's like you you've
seen Rebels enter x-wings but uh we
don't commonly see the other side of it
I think in the force awakens you see you
know the first order pilot Finn uh enter
the X-Wing or enter the Tie Fighter but
this is like the first time we've seen
some hanging Tie fighters that they all
run down again yeah that was very cool
uh and it kind of grounded us with these
guys in their in their cockpits so uh
kimzey from the tower catches on to the
heist and leads a group down to the
Vault where they engage in this shootout
you know the Corporal realizes that Gorn
uh has betrayed him we get this great
moment of you know after serving you for
seven years I deserve worse what a line
yeah what a line I think that is the
moment where the corporal's heart breaks
really yeah he's like but we've had
dinners together
you've dined in my home
big dinners second portions of dinners
dinner before we both died
the deaths happened too fast here like
Gorn gets shot and we barely Linger on
it terraman asks skiing for cover and we
were wondering later could skin have
been testing and or uh maybe but skein
did totally leave terribon out to dry
here you took one shot and then hid
behind the wall leaving for terraman to
get gunned down seconds later if he had
just continued firing tearman would have
made it to the freighter but clearly
skein was going uh about this with the
Pirate game in mind just take away all
the other people to split the hole with
piece of [ __ ] uh but um Cassian quickly
starts his freighter just a little too
quickly before the payload is locked
down leaving it to slide back and Crush
nimik
ouch Belle gives the name basically the
Star Wars equivalent of an adrenaline
shot so he can read off the directions
from his Polaroid star path unit yeah
Cassian manages this daring Escape
through the gorgeous eye of all Donnie
meteor shower not a meteor shower
because it's really just a planet
passing through the the crystalline belt
or whatever Tie fighters get destroyed
in the shower it's such a a
well-directed well-edited well shot
sequence it's just so much fun I loved
it I love that Polaroid star path unit
by the way that was me too what a great
shout out to my friend Liv who
identified the exact uh Polaroid camera
being used yeah it's yeah like a 72
whatever it's uh very very specific and
it seems like it takes a moment to
recharge too which is fun Star Wars has
a rich history of using like camera
equipment to create their props I mean
the lightsaber hilts are famously flash
flash ball like holders from Kodak
cameras right I think yeah
um uh I because you gotta imagine all
these folks are working on a film set so
they're just kind of looking around at
photography and other things might be
lying right that kind of equipment
lighting equipment sound equipment
um so that's I love this
um so we had this little debate over
whether or not to bring nemec to the
doctor that they have on standby and now
looking back we realized that scheme
just did this so that he could have a
moment alone with the hall and have Val
separated and whatever this medical tent
was which is just a bummer because it
seems like a moment where it paints Vel
in a bad light so it's like okay that
was a little more driven than we thought
and then skiing we thought was a
bleeding heart now both of them kind of
suck because I mean they're all
motivated I'm not saying the characters
are poorly written it's just like we
like them a little bit less but it's
also for the show's benefit I think it
just shows these Rebels as like real
people yeah who have complex motivations
and are willing to you know not save the
cat I I appreciated that uh so while
they're sitting around while this doctor
looks like a member knees doctor by the
way and you know mimbon was where
Cassian fought in the War alongside Han
Solo and Chewie such as that that's an
interesting thing there
um they uh they had this moment between
Skeen and Cassian where they're debating
hey should we split the payload uh Skeen
says that he has no brother Cassian
shoots him dead inside the tent we
learned that nemec has died on the
operating table Cassian gives Vel
luthin's kyber Crystal to return to
Luton and he says that he's just only
going to take his promise cut of the
credits and leave the rest with her
belgus Cassian nimics Manifesto uh so
Party Guys orders all ISB officers to
prepare a retaliation plan in the
Imperial Senate mon mothma makes the
plea to Aid the Gormans it's hard to
tell I was looking for like cameos among
the other Senators it looks like on the
central days we do see like this pale
figure that I think might be Sly more
and she kind of has that pale skin in
the bald head
um because this slide more did get
mentioned earlier in the series and I
think at this point she would be
standing in as kind of the the
representative for the emperor yeah yeah
gonna be her job yeah she notices uh
some other Senators reacting to the all
Donny news that news reaches Lutheran in
the shop he goes around order to
celebrate a little too loudly I assume
these random patrons aren't really like
spying on him for any reason but he
doesn't really like but that wasn't hide
it that was a great like one-line Cameo
casting of the dude who's like do you
have anything from uh algani or whatever
and he was like I was like oh this dude
looks evil he's gonna like shoot him or
something like he's like an imperial
Imperial uh officer or something but
yeah uh I think he was like wait I was
just kidding why would you have anything
from that planet are you crazy it was a
joke no come back he sure bet he should
have been credited as Rich prick at the
end that should have been that should
have been his role Rich one of the Nick
curl characters yes Pricks exactly you
know if if Nick Kroll ever shows up in
Star Wars he's gonna play so grounded
he's not gonna play but if he's
characters yeah well that's too bad and
that's what we want from him he should
voice an alien then he can do it like
Simon pay yeah we got you uncar plot be
like just having
uh but yeah Luther's super excited oh
the new wigs will be able to buy now he
has 80 million credits good for him I'm
happy for him I love him all right Tommy
let's jump right to the question yes uh
uh no ifs and or butts about it Eric is
aldani f oh boy uh yeah what is next
what's how will the uh Empire strike
back here I mean structurally this
season of Andor is broken up into four
three season chunks the first three
episodes were centering around pharynx
and casting getting away from the
premore cops as they were investigating
the murder uh the second three obviously
focused on this aldani heist mission
this season is uh not done with either
of those planets though last episode
showed up the Empire setting up a
presence on ferrics taking over their
Hotel trailer footage proves that things
will return there we know there's gonna
be some like writing that happens there
and that um in that Dedra Miro is gonna
show up on on ferricks this Rebel
victory in all Donnie though is a very
very big deal judging from the reaction
from Lutheran from the Senators like the
reaches the Senators and they leave like
uh um like an open session of the Senate
to like react to it uh and then the way
uh party cats Bradley the troops of the
ISB yeah this is a huge deal I mean it
is a quarter of the of the sector
Imperials payload right and party guy
says I want every Star sector and
planetary emergency retaliation plan in
the building ready for presentation by
midnight now I didn't look at anyone's
clock maybe it was like 11 52. right
like by midnight midnight tonight why
what uh can I get an extension I was
sleeping now remember Santa was left
behind in all Donnie she dressed herself
as an Imperial Guard she joined the
pilgrims uh her captive saw her face
throughout all this which makes us
worried how she's gonna get out of here
though trailer footage just show her
retrieving a Speeder bike and then
looking up in fear at a massive Star
Destroyer that arrives to this planet so
the Empire is pulling out all the stops
you don't bring a star destroyer just to
you know investigate you it's a battle
station they're gonna wreck this place
so will the Imperial retaliation be to
bomb the [ __ ] out of all Donnie and all
of its pilgrims will the sacred Temple
be destroyed how do you think the Empire
is gonna strike back and will it just
escalate things worse you know I believe
that there's going to be more of a
debate than just simply going back and
bombing the uh the ever living uh uh
crap out of out of the aldani I think
that what we're going to see is a
struggle for what strategy who to blame
a struggle for blame because they're
going to be like how could it have been
the aldani Shepherds and pilgrims who we
have such little respect for we don't
even we think of them as like simple
tins who don't even bathe properly right
like we're like we the the the the the
explanation of even like we just set
taverns up on the way here and so many
of them just get drunk and party that
they don't even make it to this actual
thing they start as 1500 the end is 60.
which I think will begin a debate within
the Empire of like this is a this is a
large I mean not that they don't already
know there's a rebellion but like we
need to find out who is the power supply
of this Rebellion you know who's who's
got the money who's got the tech who's
got the who's got the Manpower person
power so I think there's going to be a
struggle leading to that looks like
there's going to be a um
uh a bombing of the aldani but I think
at the last minute it's going to get
called off when they're going to realize
that like either uh loosen or perhaps
even Monmouth having to go underground
are are two are to be held responsible
for this Heist that's my theory that's
an interesting thought there Tommy I'm
wondering if they might bomb part of the
planet some of the more sacred stuff
that we saw in some of those um um
pilgrims might not make it out but that
that might be part of like the 3D chess
by the rebellion and people like saw
Guerrera that they may either use this
after the fact or be waiting for a test
case in order to further the rebels
propaganda message remember in Rogue one
they they kept the Death Star plan
secret because they didn't want the like
the independent systems and the people
who were kind of happy to be subjugated
by the Empire to realize that the Empire
had this wmd that could quash any kind
of uh representation right or any kind
of descent right
um so I think think there were factions
of the Empire who are like maybe we
should not be building a super weapon
like this or maybe like if we are
definitely don't let it out there until
it's finished right uh because it it
hurts our our propaganda message that
we're just trying to provide peace in
the Galaxy
um so if something like this happens I
think there's going to be some hawkish
factions of the Empire who want revenge
We Want Blood for Blood and Money and
they want their money back yeah right oh
for sure I think that's already going to
be a problem but yeah I think they're
going to uh obviously they plan to strip
this this Valley anyway to to build an
Imperial base and I think they're going
to expedite those plans uh and that that
will be used by people like Lutheran by
mon mothma by sagarera and whoever else
they want to join the the leadership uh
to further the propaganda message out
there it's kind of like what Leia told
Tarkin uh the more you you tighten your
grip the more star systems slip through
your fingers and that's what's going to
happen here they're going to try to
tighten their rip and and snuff out
descent but in doing so a lot of people
are going to look at this massacre that
happens on aldani and be like whoa whoa
you guys have no claim to try to lie to
us and say that you're providing peace
you guys are War mongers uh you guys are
monsters uh I think ultimately that's
what's gonna happen I think maybe it
necessarily wasn't about the money per
se it was about the message
and they were identifying you know it's
kind of like when you hear of these
famous Supreme Court cases that get uh
they get brought all the way to the
Supreme Court when you look into the
specifics of the case itself normally
you're like
really that's what this is over right
and it's because lawyers specifically
identify a test case that they can use
uh to most rally around like public to
make it the to make it the distance all
the way through the federal courts all
the Supreme Court
um they're they're looking for like a
very specific set of conditions that
will help them best make the the legal
argument not necessarily one that is
like the most truest outrage necessarily
if that makes sense a lot of protest
movements will do that too like famously
there was like another woman before Rosa
Parks who wasn't as good of a like an
example of that message and once Rosa
Parks refused to get up for a bus like
the whole Civil Rights Movement was like
yes yes let's run with this instrument
with this because that's part of the
strategy sure it's part of the activist
strategy is you have to like figure out
what parts of your narrative are most
going to move the needle and bring more
people to your cause like you have to do
this you have to yeah absolutely so I I
think that's what's going to happen I
think this is going to be the first step
in an escalation by the Empire I'm
nervous uh I'm nervous so yeah this
brings us to the question of what really
is next for Cassian specifically nimix
Manifesto Tommy I think we've talked
about this a little bit but like that
Manifesto I think is going to be hugely
important yeah I think it's going to be
arguably the most important at least
prop to make it out of this series and
I'm so excited to see how nemec's
thoughts his teachings his uh his late
night uh creep thoughts will influence
many characters we've met before
couldn't uh we could find out that this
gets uh in the hands not only of
sagarrera but people of the crew of the
ghosts maybe we find out a young pilot
named Luke Skywalker's reading it right
before the trench room right but what do
you think is next for all this yeah I
mean I wonder how much Cassian is gonna
read it and how much more he's gonna
distribute it you know like I think
he'll read it but like Cassian has his
like even through Rogue one his own
agenda and his own way of dealing in the
Rebellion so yeah I think it'll be
tremendously important I wonder is it a
thing where he gives it to Lutheran and
Lutheran gets it Mass distribute it
seems like someone with a little more
power and money is going to have to get
their hands on it to distribute it right
and and to kind of uh I don't I you know
I I don't know if they have a uh
Galactic version of the Gutenberg
printing press but uh we're gonna need
some some sort of uh electron maybe they
can upload it or something maybe it gets
beamed out
to all across the Galaxy maybe maybe
that's like uh some sort of like uh end
of an episode scene is like just
billions of copies of this Manifesto
getting in the hands of people
everywhere winning the hearts and Minds
as they say yeah I think what would be
hard about this is we we live in this
era of Star Wars where it's essentially
Space Nazis so subjugated everything so
things like books it's going to be hard
to distribute books right like that's
like the first thing they start burning
right and the Nazis take over right
um and the first thing is they start
restricting yeah like free access to
literature like that so it might get
transposed into some other form like I
could see a great podcast uh maybe a six
episode streaming series version of um
of nimix Manifesto welcome back to the
Daily I'm Tommy bechtold and with me is
my co-host Eric Voss today we're just
we're discussing the uh zenix Manifesto
yeah
um I I uh I think like a lot of things
in Star Wars like it's not so much about
what's written in the book you know Last
Jedi famously Yoda said page Turners
they were not I would imagine nimix
Manifesto is a hell of a page Turner for
one I'd rather sit down with that than
like the Jedi Code I want him to be like
you know he was so kind of like
I don't I don't want to say Dopey he was
he was a Dopey but he was so like kind
of sweet and soft like the way he spoke
was like everything will be good it'll
be all right you could like this this
will keep you alive this is good and
then the manifesto's like if you do not
crush this Empire we will be cry like
it's all like the language is just very
aggressive we must rip out the heart of
the snake
you know um he said that like the
chapter he wrote which would have been
the last chapter of this if you think
about it because he wrote it the night
before the mission I don't think he had
time on the mission to write another
entry he called it he gave it a chapter
heading saying the role of mercenaries
in the galactic struggle for Freedom
talking specifically about castanander
he said he didn't mention his name
clamor Cassian but you have to imagine
that that chapter will be read by
someone like Princess Leia and that will
justify why she's like okay we need Han
Solo if money is like there's there's so
many parallels in the series between
Cassian and hunting right I can't help
but see this well is it read by someone
like you say Luke Skywalker almost makes
more sense in the sense that when they
get to The Cantina to find a pilot
Kenobi seems more like apprehensive of
Han Solo and Luke is like this guy can
do it he'll be great like I mean this is
what like I didn't realize Star Wars
needed this so much until I watched this
show yeah it's just they needed their
Thomas Paine they needed uh their John
Locke they needed their um you know
Patrick Henry their political thinkers
yeah
um they're uh Rousseau their Machiavelli
they're everybody they're revolutionary
philosophical underpinnings because yeah
we get that the Empire is evil right but
we need something that the rebels are
fighting for um and obviously not every
Rebel is going to have read this
paperwork not everyone's really going to
think about it that deeply that's the
case in any Revolution yeah people
everyone has their own Rebellion they're
fighting for their own motivations which
is fine uh but there has to be someone
in this movement that uh gets the uh
what's the word I'm looking for gets the
intellectual class involved uh so at
least this is going to be distributed
for between Mon mothma and and her
friends like in who's my mother
mentoring Leia at this point in history
or has sometime recently so yeah don't
be surprised if this book comes back and
gets in the hands of someone that we
know I think uh we need someone to pass
this Manifesto even if doesn't get Mass
distributed these teachings I think are
going to be influenced a lot of people
and you're going to see a lot of people
on the series at least quoting what
nimik said or speaking that kind of
language probably like misquoting it and
bastardizing it getting it wrong we're
gonna see someone turning this into a
rap musical at some point oh and people
are really gonna love it then there's
gonna be a backlash then there's gonna
be a backlash to the backlash and it's
just gonna go back and forth I think the
important thing is that we argue about
it and don't give any good faith
yes assume the worst from everyone yeah
now on another reminder things are going
to go back to ferrics uh Cassian and Vel
are probably going to end up back
together because we see Vel uh the
actress who plays Val in trailer footage
on an imperial occupied Barracks uh
she's standing in Alleyway as
Stormtroopers are Marching past so
somehow these two are going to end up
back together I have to imagine that I
don't know if Cassian would want to go
back to ferrics right now because he
just like left that planet and there's
probably still a death warrant out for
his arrest so what do you think where do
you think Cassian is literally gonna go
next we know he's gonna be part of
another mission on some like uh forced
labor camp like what do we think the
next three episodes are going to be
about I think the next three episodes
may I think we end back in pharynx I
think the next three might be Lutheran
giving him another assignment like
you're willing to do this you did a
great job with that I mean at this point
though I guess it's so important for him
to remain I mean the theme of the fact
that the Empire never learns because
they they they're so like they're just
so powerful they never like they never
learn from any of their mistakes it's
kind of leading up to him just doing a
similar thing again right like he's
gonna Infiltrate The Empire again that's
kind of what he does he goes in and they
don't even notice because they're so fat
and satisfied we got the literal
manifestation of that in this episode
episode of a fat and satisfied
commanding officer so I would say
Lutheran probably sends him out to get
something else or I mean not to make it
like a you know Mandalorian go out and
do this thing and you know solve this
problem for us and we'll give you this
but you know looking at I I would
imagine it's a it's a mission now and or
by himself I think we now we've seen and
door with a team now we can handle by
himself and then I assume we probably
end this season or this half of the
series with Andor returning to ferrics
to you know save his friends or or save
his his uh stepmother yeah we know
Lutheran will be meeting sargerara
sometimes right I assume the next three
episodes it's going to be something with
the partisans the other Mission and I
wonder if casting will now go back to
his original objective from the opening
scene of trying to find his sister yeah
that we might learn some more
information about what was happening on
qunari yeah uh and that might further
motivate him uh to uh you know use them
use his kind of the winnings to fund
Rebel efforts maybe he loses it at some
point maybe he gets robbed by Han and
Chewie no I mean that's a lot of money
that he just got yeah it's bigger than
this money what is a rebellion gonna do
with 80 million credits I've looked I
did some um some Financial breakdown to
what all this is uh x-wings reportedly
cost 150 000 of our money okay or 150
000 credits uh new 65 000 credits used
okay and if you convert that to 1977
using on the exchange rate uh that would
be I don't think you have to do that I'm
just kidding a used X-Wing for 13 Grand
I could almost afford that I'm pretty
good pretty good if I could get these
people to give me a raise I mean you are
necessary to get in the building Tommy
that's right I think that I think
why someone's coming from my hand Eric
oh God oh God no
well I think the um either they could
buy a ton of x-wings with it I wonder if
this is now going to be what Luton
brings to saw Guerrera and he's like
okay
you needed money to buy more equipment
more ships uh to recruit more people and
maybe a fun new pet yeah
[Music]
so that money we need someone to to hug
people so hard they have to tell the
truth
is a saltwater animal
oh I think you're using pork belly for
other things so no no no no no no
business it's a business expense you use
it suction cups to get the truth that's
all no one is being sucked no one is
being sucked kid
no you have to believe me Jim no one is
being sucked
all right so why don't you just sit down
and drink a glass of blue milk for a
second okay bud all right lactose
intolerant
I'm gonna blow gauntlets if I drink that
milk
I'm loving this show so much I don't
know what's gonna happen in the last six
episodes I kind of love that yes this
show is such a ride and what a
beautifully written show I love all the
characters I don't want any of them to
die but I love that the show will kill
off several of them yeah
um and we'll leave it there for this
episode of WikiLeaks again Easter egg
breakdown for this episode it's coming
tomorrow please watch it I feel like I
do a good job breaking down some cool
stuff in that episode and tell your
friends to watch the show because it's
awesome slaps uh Tommy and I will be
back next Wednesday with our reaction
episode 7 of Andor you can follow Tommy
at tommybackto follow me at yavos follow
new Rockstar subscribe to WikiLeaks
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
for watching and we have spoke
foreign